don't say men have it harder just based
off the fact that like girls could walk
around saying that they're tense like
the inflated self-esteem that social
media has provided has made the average
woman way happier than the average man
the average man is like a lot of them
are invisible and miserable now and we
don't talk about that the self-deletion
rate being five times higher for men
than women is something that like no
one's selling solution but we talk about
the wage Gap in a rovey with not being
able to kill a baby is why women are
oppressed it's nonsense
what thought is that though
we're talking about it right now no
you're talking about it right now it's a
difference
okay well I meant the thing about fresh
and fit is that they do get like I feel
like the dumbest girls you know what I
mean I'm yet to see like a good
intellectual it's all only strategic I
mean no I know it is it's for the
content we gotta go on fresh and fit
we're not talking about it we're talking
about he goes we are talking about it
she says you're talking about it women
what was that like was that was that
supposed to be an intelligent comeback
that was ridiculous men typically
suppressed I understand what he's saying
though but I'm just saying like Society
doesn't give a [ __ ] about my problems
Society doesn't give a [ __ ] about that
you call us you say in-cell or quick to
like all these like insults problematic
toxic that's how you belong
yeah who hurt you they always say that
one
they always say that just for being
realistic who hurt you yeah who
like no we're just being realistic here
we're just talking about what's going on
in my life and the funny thing is that
the advice they give you is like bad
advice like they'll tell you like yeah
you can be emotional and like expose
yourself and cry in front of your
girlfriend and that's just like horrible
advice you know the stuff they tell you
to do is actually wrong yeah have you
noticed that I I think in an extreme
situation your whole family was killed
in a helicopter crash yeah it's okay to
break down in front of your girlfriend
if it happens but you know just over
every little thing you really we are
teaching men to become feminine and it's
messing with their minds and they're
unhappy because it's against their
nature I've said it before it's like
whatever you would look at your parents
doing that's what you should be looking
to do as a man so like if you don't want
your dad sitting there crying when [ __ ]
gets hard then you're gonna take that
role eventually in your family so you
shouldn't be doing it with your
potential wife and the kids in front of
you you know what I'm saying that's kind
of the way I look at stuff if like your
dad's gonna [ __ ] about something or
he's not going to talk to your mom that
way then you shouldn't do you shouldn't
do it either I feel like that's always a
good analogy to go to you know what I
mean but people don't know that there's
another way to live that there are other
you know they may not spend a lot of
time at a household whether it's family
or neighbors or friends where things are
healthy and normal and there's and there
are Role Models they may think that this
is how people act and it really is true
that people get caught in cycles and
that's unfortunate because yes you
should be able to look at your parents
and and look at how you were brought up
and say this was wonderful and I want to
take this with me as for the rest of my
life but this didn't work and I'm not
going to [ __ ] about it forever I am
going to change it in myself yeah at
some point have something different in
my own personal and professional life
right at some point you take
self-accountability and you look at
because especially with the internet
nowadays and you can find so many good
Role Models like you can just like watch
like the Tates videos there's so many
different people that you could look up
to and adopt their thinking rather than
your shitty father that's true and I do
hope that everybody gets exposure to
that kind of thing yeah but it's funny
when they cancel them when I was a
surgery if you were if you yeah I know
when I was a kid if you were insulated
you know insulated from the outside
world you really were insulated from the
outside world now you know at least some
of those kids that don't have so
in-person social interaction or decent
family you know extended families they
do have a phone to look into but what's
happening though is they're going down
dark ugly paths instead of necessarily
finding really positive content well
yeah it's I mean I don't want to go too
deep into it but it's anyway yeah sorry
cancel once a month every day
[Music]
when you talk about the real problems
when I say that men delete themselves
five times more than women you're like
who hurt you who hurts why men don't
talk about it
you're not comforting yourself is what I
hear out of you you don't think I'm
confident in myself when you're speaking
as a whole as in like guys in general
the average guy is way less confident
than the average woman the average woman
you're running around saying who felt is
that that's our fault it's not your
fault it's trickle down you're being
brainwashed it's not just men's fault
you're being brainwashed by the top
Christian they fed you this idea they
still get started bro
ladies always joking
but they sell for it but they sell for
it but it doesn't matter whose fault it
is it's the top it's the programming
that's coming you don't realize it
that's why you sit here confidently I'm
a 10. but that you can really break that
down and realize like no average guy is
going to come in here and say I'm the
10.
and you said based off looks why would I
rate my look lower than a I'm sorry I
can't do that because I'm confident in
myself
that's just delusion though is he also
talking about just looks like she just
went to straight looks that it's it's
all about I mean I know when we're
saying she's a 10 he's a 10 it usually
is of Outlook so I'm not trying to go
too deep but you know she's all about
looks and saying she's confident and she
should rate herself as a 10. what do you
think
so I'm not asking what you rate her I'm
asking what you think about that I think
that there's a difference between
confidence and being realistic you know
what I mean like I'm gonna go up to a
girl and have full confidence and think
I'm the [ __ ] and like who else would she
talk to here but realistically I also
acknowledge that there's room to grow
and I'm not perfect you know what I mean
yeah common Sony wrestling
do that to myself because I ripped
myself higher because it's gonna give me
confidence in myself to do better and
want yeah you delude yourselves with
confidence
yeah that's the thing with men it's not
deluding yourselves you have to like
earn it like the reason Tate is so
confident is because he's basically
become that guy I don't know well if we
could talk ourselves into it why can't
men is what she's saying like no you
can't like you because like as a guy you
have to earn all that [ __ ] that makes
you that makes you a real G you know you
can't just be like this yeah but but she
thinks she's a g even if she's not so
you can in your mind but
side worlds you can't right she could
say she's a 10 all day long the outside
world doesn't necessarily have to agree
with her it's about her mindset yeah no
I mean I hear what you're saying like
you could still be confident and
realistic in my opinion like I could
acknowledge that you know even though
I'm like much more successful than like
everyone else my age I'm still I still I
don't feel like you know a 10 out of 10.
yeah I think the real thing though is
here just to get back to the Crux of it
is you know we're not walking around
telling women that they're not good
enough all they do is tell women you're
beautiful as you are we love you and I
mean it's actually a bunch of horseshit
really not everybody is beautiful you
know it's not okay to you know weigh an
extra hundred pounds because you're
going to have heart disease and diabetes
but they're they're beating women all
this brainwashing that you're wonderful
the way you are when you have no
personality and you know you're walking
around dressed like a hoe and you look
cheap right so anyway then but with men
all we do is all they're getting these
days is beaten down you're toxic you
know your your masculinity itself is is
cruel and toxic and privileged male
privilege White Privilege like it just
goes on and on so we just in in this new
Western Society just beating the [ __ ]
out of men all day long women don't have
to deal with that you know I so so he's
right like it is different and she so it
is not the same where you can just be
like Oh I'm a 10 regardless you know I
just kind of undid what I my initial
Theory very nice zoned out yeah thanks
for listening yeah it looks though you
ain't saying nothing else about nothing
else but that's what we're gonna have to
offer but if I think I'll attend like
fine I'm gonna rate myself for 10 fine
confidence and then delusion oh that's
the same thing I just said so here's the
thing very very quick because I was
observing this whole exchange just now
he stated objective fact and in response
to him stating an objective fact you
guys said who hurt you what he said
about men committing suicide is no
different than me saying it's cloudy
outside
well if I say it's cloudy outside and
actually it's cloudy outside a response
of who hurts you it would be stupid
wouldn't it just in general since the
beginning was
a little painful well we're telling the
truth though wait a minute so so why how
does telling the truth and Reporting
fact make you hurt you it's not telling
the truth because he's speaking based
off him if there's other people okay
they're dead they've killed themselves
that's the fact that he's talking about
everything he stated since say one thing
can you name one thing no I cannot
exactly think about it if you give me an
hour I got you okay
I'm talking
just everything he said name one thing
if I said everything say one thing that
I said things that you were saying gave
me low self-esteem
no confidence
that's just how I felt like giving no
confidence I'm talking about the average
guy I'm talking about statistics you're
going to based off you I can't what the
hell are you talking about
this girl's trying so hard to just make
any points that she can't even buy my
only fans can they just buy my own
inject button that they can just like
she could just fall through the floor
now you know you know she's plugging her
her [ __ ] though
when you actually talk about the real
[ __ ] going on oh you're thinking about
everybody
about everybody you're not everybody
you're only one person oh let's be
careful honey because you're sure it has
opinions about everybody what is up with
these girls that they get like where do
they find these they find them in like a
the gutters come on like what's up with
this
is what girls do because a lot of other
girls probably feel the same way and
they're just not gonna say it because
they don't want to you know stand on
their beliefs but what I've come to
realize is
when a girl says who hurts you whatever
it's not because it's not because what
you're saying is incorrect it's well
it's it's not even how you said it's
about how what you said made them feel
right so objective if you say something
that offends them it makes them feel a
certain way right the natural response
it's a human thing it's a self-defense
mechanism is well who hurt you because
you're stating these facts that don't
make me feel good even though that's
such a fact what's what's that called
when you do that there's like all that
like there's like the straw man there's
like all the different types of
arguments there's a name for that yeah
it is a manipulation and you're just
like oh it's it's almost like
gaslighting in a sense I feel like if
it's not exactly gaslighting it's in the
gaslighting family yeah no if you're
spitting facts then you're just like oh
my god what happened to you yeah yeah
because what happened yeah [ __ ] you like
you're not like it's and it's one thing
to really be a human being and say it's
not like you said hey did something
happen like tell me more about that like
what what how did you get to that place
like that's that's asking and being
curious but who hurt you is obnoxious it
is
[ __ ] these hoes and he's just going off
and like all women are trash like he's
just dating his opinion and he didn't
even talk about women he really too much
he was basically talking about men they
said that women are delusional anything
he just said everything you said give me
an hour to give me a specific answer
that's nonsense it's the truth can you
just shut up her mic he specifically
named something that she said she looks
drunk
right now
because we didn't just speak about this
10 minutes ago so why is it why is it
that we're able to recall certain things
that you guys have said and bring it
back but you can't do you think
well they're not smarter they're not
that smart
what oh this one yeah
you don't make any sense right now no no
just based off what you're saying I'm
still gonna say what I said before is
you just giving off that Vibe okay
the Sagittarius Vibe let's finish this
video this is hurting my brain you're
not bothering me anyway I'm just saying
what you're saying is just so negative
like it's the truth I don't care it can
make you feel negative that or that's
the truth okay
to be true or you're just saying like
it's true based off what you're saying
men delete themselves five times more
than one coming out your mouth
so how are you saying that it's based on
what he said or how he feels
five times more
statistics though what did I say that
was not based on a statistic
I can't remember anything you just read
the chest
it comes back to like I said this is
very very common like if you make a girl
feel a certain way for her to attack
your argument I honestly think the thing
is is that she just like couldn't even
recall what they just talked about no
she couldn't again she she really could
have just said about five minutes ago uh
you know what can you just I'm sorry
could you just repeat yourself because I
wasn't listening because that's really
what she should have said because she
wasn't listening she was this is a clear
example of somebody that was just
sitting there waiting to disagree NPCs
waiting to waiting to disagree and try
to make a point and she couldn't even
you know all she had to do was latch
onto one thing he said and be specific
and she couldn't do that without
necessarily no she got a tattoo and say
who hurt you but like here's the thing
if I take like a scholarly individual
that has a PHD a [ __ ] and maybe you
know a male and then a female whatever
it may be right and they all say the sky
is blue right are you going to sit there
and be like who hurt you who hurt you
you're the one who said who hurt you I
just yeah okay okay no she's making no
sense
sneaker wants it wants to hit the
objective my tripping or didn't she just
didn't she just say that I don't care I
don't care like she was she was who
hurry up eject what are you gonna do we
just got stupider watching that I just
got like stupider thank you guys for
watching make sure to like subscribe
join my Discord and follow my Instagram
at Sunny Fez don't follow hers so mine
has more dog pictures
[Music]
[Music]